Відвідуючи анексований Крим,
російський президент Володимир Путін
на суднобудівному заводі у Керчі зробив несподівану заяву.
Він послався на слова українського прем'єр-міністра у 2010-2014 роках Миколи Азарова.
З останнім прем'єром багато розмовляли, ще коли він був прем'єром.
Я кажу: що ви робите? Чого гроші з Криму забираєте?
Він говорить: у нас немає вибору. Крим щось генерує
і ми вимушені забирати звідти більше, ніж давати,
для того, щоб підтримати інші регіони України.
Російський президент у своїй промові не наводив жодних конкретних цифр,
скільки ж Крим віддавав до бюджету України, та не зазначав роки, які він має на увазі,
тож розгляньмо виплати до бюджету і дотації автономної республіки
в останній рік перед анексією - 2013-й.
За даними Держстату і Держказначейства України,
абсолютними рекордсменами у перерахуваннях до держбюджету
у 2013 році були Дніпропетровська, Харківська та Полтавська області.
На Дніпропетровщині видобувають залізну руду, на Харківщині - газ та нафту,
на Полтавщині - усі ці копалини. Вони приносять бюджету
значні суми рентних платежів та плати за користування надрами.
Найбільш дотаційними регіонами у 2013 році були, зокрема,
Донецька, Луганська, Івано-Франківська, Закарпатська області
та автономна республіка Крим.
Півострів перерахував того року до держбюджету України
1 мільярд 940 мільйонів гривень, а отримав дотацій на 5 мільярдів 720 мільйонів.
Тобто півострів отримав утричі більше грошей, ніж віддав до бюджету.
Цікаво, що журналіст "Інвестгазети" Артем Захарченко
ще в січні 2014-го, у розпал Революції гідності,
у матеріалі "Зона проїдання" розвінчав міф про те, що нібито Донбас "годує" Україну.
У цьому ж дослідженні були й дані стосовно Криму.
Абсолютним лідером у 2013 році щодо профіциту на душу населення
унаслідок своєї економічної діяльності була Полтавська область,
яка мала плюс 3757 гривень на людину.
Щодо Криму, то він того року мав дефіцит на душу населення у мінус 1919 гривень на особу.
Усі ці дані Держстату і Держказначейства
одними з перших у країні лягали на стіл тодішньому прем'єру Миколі Азарову
і він точно був у курсі, що Крим не є профіцитним регіоном, який "годує" Україну.
Спростувань або підтверджень розмови з Путіним
щодо бюджетних успіхів Криму до анексії від пана Азарова не пролунало.
На підставі офіційної статистики Держказначейства і Держстату
можна зробити висновок, що заява російського президента у Керчі
про те, що український уряд відбирав у Криму гроші
на користь інших регіонів, не відповідає дійсності.